What is that?
Oh.
Those are Japanese
box markers.
Yep.
NARRATOR: While
exploring the waterfalls
beneath the carved gorilla
face, John and his team
discover a set of markers.
Those are box markers,
meaning that there's five boxes,
it looks like, of possible--
Sure does.
--treasure.
Five boxes of gold.
Right here.
These are some of the most
compelling treasure markers
I've ever seen.
It looks like a face.
Well, it almost looks like
two sets of eyeballs and--
And it's a--
--nose coming out.
Right.
Yeah.
NARRATOR: Weeks
ago, John and Manny
found what they
believe to be the face
of a gorilla carved in
the uppermost waterfall
on the mountain.
Look at that.
NARRATOR: In the
treasure hunting world,
it is believed animal face
symbols point to treasure
based on where their
eyes are looking.
But John and Manny
weren't certain where
the gorilla marker pointed.
Finding that gorilla
face was awesome.
But I couldn't see where
the eye was looking.
But now, starting to
put it all together,
it seems like the gorilla face
is pointing to the box markers,
which is pointing
to this lower punch
bowl below the box markers.
And I think if we go down there,
we're going to find a tunnel,
and it's going to be
filled with treasure.
Oh, yeah.
The Japanese loved to
build tunnels behind falls.
NARRATOR: John thinks it's
possible Yamashita's engineers
diverted the water here,
allowing them to tunnel
behind the falls,
hiding treasure inside.
It would be very easy to
hide gold-- it would be--
hide anything down here.
Based on the markers
that we saw up top,
you know, I think this
punch bowl is-- we
need to explore it some more.
Very carefully over there.
Oh, yeah, no problem.
If there is any metal within
18 feet of this magnetometer,
it will find it.
Nothing back here.
No metal, really,
like light metal here.
But as I--
[beeping]
--bring it back into
the rock face there,
it really is
screaming down here.
[suspenseful music playing]
Oh, yeah.
Good signal, good
metallic signal.
I think there's one large
accumulation of metal
right there.
Yeah.
Wow, that's pretty incredible.
NARRATOR: Using a
magnetometer, the team
believes they have discovered
a large hit to the right
of the waterfall,
which could indicate
a significant
concentration of metal
within 18 feet of the falls.
Well, if the Japanese were
going to hide treasure here,
it would be a good
place to do it.
Now, this is a great spot.
It's totally hidden
away from everything.
NARRATOR: To get a better
look, the team decides to try
draining the plunge pool.
We're gonna drain
this pond, baby.
Fire that bad boy up.
Switch on.
Yamashita, look out!
Woo-hoo!
Yeah, there she goes, yeah.
NARRATOR: The team's
gas powered pump quickly
lowers the level
of the plunge pool,
draining the water downstream.
Hold on.
Check this out.
I got a perfect circle.
It's a tunnel marker.
NARRATOR: The team
has just discovered
a possible golden lily symbol
previously hidden under water,
which may confirm their belief
that there is a tunnel system
running under the waterfall.
Jeremy, would you
get me my magnetometer.
And that's a strong signal.
That's down 18 feet.
And it's directional, so
it's going in that direction.
One step closer, boys.
That's right.
This may be the key right here.
Going after
Yamashita's gold is
always going to be dangerous.
You know, they didn't want
you to get their treasure.
They didn't send
engineers in here
to tunnel under a waterfall
to make it easy for us.
Leave this all.